A 17 year old son pulled a tick off his stomach Tuesday morning, this is probably a month ago now, and I'm not sure if he got the whole thing out.
It was ran around the bite. Is it necessary to get the whole thing out or will it work its way out?
Now your body will heal if there's, if you leave anything in it, like a sliver or part of a bug.
But it's much better to get it out if you can.
If this tick is infected, if this tick does have veralia, then it's more important to get that out because the infected part is probably going to be the
robustness that's left in the tissue. So I'm sure this was already taken care of, but for anybody who would be forward and would have this same question,
you want to try to get it out. There are some little tick dislodging tools that you can buy on the internet.
We used to sell them at our store. I don't think we have any more, but you could just buy them on Amazon for your dogs or your cats or your children or yourself.
There's little hooks that go around the tick and your twist is called tick twisters or something like that. It pulls the tick out real nice, good thing to have.
But, you know, just because the person got a tick bite doesn't mean that they have Lyme disease or that tick was infected.
Even if that tick was infected, you have the possibility of your body killing off the bacteria and you never ended quote unquote Lyme disease because your body killed it.
It's what your body is supposed to do. Your immune system is supposed to kill enemies that are trying to attack it.
It's when your immune system is down or the infection is too great that it becomes more of a problem that the person can end up setting up this product line.
If a person does think that they have an infection and they might have evidence of that.
If they have an, you know, fever, they might feel ill that I do think, you know, knowing that, hey, I got a tick, got the tick off.
But, you know, I'm feeling ill or my child's feeling ill, they have evidence of a fever.
They don't feel well. I do think it's wise knowing how bad Borrelia could be and how bad product line could be to get an antibiotic.
For typical antibiotics, it would be used as docks of cyclic and or a moxicillin, I think it's wise to go all of that.
Now, the course of days depends on the limeliter doctor that you're going to go to anywhere between 10 days and 30 days would be the course of treatment.
It always suggested to follow that course of treatment, you're going to legally can't answer that question.
So, you're going to have to make some decisions.